‏Okay.
الرحيم
الله
محمد
وبارك
اصحابه به
المزمن
[Silence]
‏between the earliest of
back to the
‏chaptered
before what other chapter there is a
large
however we have apprations
and this
ر
صلى الله
‏some
and
beforees of other chapters and the
chapters
entirely not concluded
as a last conclusion the final
conclusion untilough
3 days before the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قران
واتقوا يوما ترجعون فيه الى الله
ثم توفى كل نفس ما كسبت وهم لا يظلمون
سوره البقره سوره البقره
10 years
allally
ag
اقرا
سوره المدثر سوره المزمل سوره نون والقلم
سوره القلم
سوره المزمل
الله سبحانه
يا ايها المزمل
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول الله تعالى
قم الليل الا قليلا
نصفه او انقص منه قليلا او زد عليه ورتل
القران ترتيلا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
او
مزمل
قم الليل الا قليلا
نصفه او انقص منه قليلا
او زد عليه ورتل القران ترتيلار
[Silence]
in a
man not necessar slowly
ان شاء الله تعالى قوله يا ايها المزمل
هذه الايه
شبيهه بايه المدثر يقول الله تعالى يا
ايها المدثر
والاصل في هذه الكلمه يا ايها المتزمل
متزمل
لكن
تخفيفا
قلبت التاء
الى زاي
واضغمت الزاي بالزاي فصارت
مزمل
والا فالاصل متزمل نفس الشيء بمدثر
لماذا؟ لتجانس المخارج
مدثر
التاء والدال
من نفس المكان تقريبا هذا اسمه تجانس
متدثر
ف تقلب التاء دالا لان التاء مفهومه
تخفيفا على القائل
في درج الكلام وكذلك الزاي الزاي من حروف
التصفير
وهي قريبه المخرج
من التاء
والتاء مفهومه فتقلب الزاي فتقلب التاء
الزايا ثم تدغم الزا
الزاي بالزاي فبتصير
زاده
مزمل
الزلم
الخفاء
اللف هنا
اذا لفيت الشيء واخفيته
كان مزملا
هيك بيقولوا العرب يسمون
الشيء المزمل هو الشيء الملفوف المخفي هذا
يسمى هذا هو الزلم في اللغه
المزمل
‏W up and hidden in what? Hi in his
hiden in his beding right hidden in the
sheets and the comforter what we call
comforter the blankets of his of his bed
is what we call when a person w up
in his
المزمل والمدثر
المدثر
المزمل
[Silence]
ولذلك يقولون الدثار
هو غير الشعار تعرفون الحديث في صحيح
البخاري يقول
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الانصار شعار والناس دثار
الانصار شعار
والناس دثار
الشعار هو اللباس الذي يلاق الجلد
هذه اللي بسموها
الملبوسات التحتيه عننا بقولوا لها يعني
اي مش عارف عندكم هذه اللغه بس نحن بنقول
الشلحه الشالحه اللي هي بت الواحد بيلبسها
تحت الفانيلا بيلبسها تحت الاواعي ماشي
هذه تسمى شعارا
هذا شعار لانه ماذا يشعر به على الجلد
مباشره لانه ملاسق للجلد الدثار
يكون فوق الشعار يلبس فقوله
الانصار شعار والناس دثار ايش يعني هذا
الكلام؟ يعني الانصار هم الحاشيه الداخليه
والناس باقي الناس هذول ابعاد الانصار هم
المقربون
الى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
الانصار شعار والناس دثا
المدثر
المزمل
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قم
يا ايها المدثر قم فان
صلاه
privزم
قم فان
قم
ان المدثر
قم فانذر
ان المزمل
قم
‏was صلى الله عليه وسلم قران
اقرا
قم
اقرا اقرا
you don't
know that kind of you know kind of
obvious of course you would learn
‏PR
people prar
before to do anything
people pr the answer is
most people want to jump right to the
you can see it even the most simple of
things for instance a person wants to
make a then
they would the
‏make
all
to
attempt to make it no first attempt is
let me go ahad and try my hand you know
give it a shot and if you know I make a
mistake here and there I'll learn on the
way
would you just
imagine this would you just try your
hand at flying ae
‏you I'll learn as I go you I'll just
jump in the cockpit,
you know, just roll with the punches
whever they take us. Is that how we do
things? What about building a
skyscraper? We just learn as we go, you
know, just start and hey, you got to
start somewhere, right? And we learn as
we go along.
‏But then why is it that we don't do
things with that which could
in seriously
grave physical har even death?
We think that's absurd to start trying
to do something before you learn how to
do it. But then when it comes to aspects
of placing our soul at haard we just go
ahad and jump in feet first with both
feet.
‏And so often people
for instance when they go for you will
people thousands of people who are
learning as they go
is someone going toarch
completely and entirely
and learn from the schar of Islam how to
perform this great active.
‏because
areakes
are
الامام البخاري رحمه اللهح
باب
العلم قبل القول والعمل
‏before statement and
you don't do anything you don't say
anything in the way of the worship of
Allah until you have first learn until
you have first learned how
what is exactly expected and then you
begin to practice and ‏So we have that's
the first one. The second one is
stand.
Now that's repeated twice. We can learn
a lot from this. Number one,
action
is the fruit of knowledge.
You learn in order that you may
implement.
‏You learn in order to have some consqu
to that know you learn in order to
have actions
knowledge that is just kep in the realm
of the abstract right it's just facts
that I know and I know a lot but you
know we don't really do that much of it.
الله
[Silence]
يقول تعالى انما التوبه على الله للذين
يعملون السوء بجهاله
يعني كان جاهل بالحكم لا لان هذا معذور
اصلا لا يحتاج الى توبه بجهاله بمعنى
بجاهل العمل
ظالم نفسه قال موسى اعوذ بالله ان اكون من
الجاهلين
لانه يكون جاهلا اذا لم يعمل بعلمه ويقول
الراجز
وعالما بعلمه لم يعملان معذب من قبل عباد
الوثن اعوذ بالله
ويقول علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
العلم هتف
استجاب والا ارتحل
يعني طالب بالعمل
فان استجاب
بقي وان لم يستجب العمل ارتحل ارتحل عنه
راح الى غيره لان العلم عزيز
العلم
هتف
استجاب والا ارتحل رضي الله عنه
انس ‏So
not only do we have once but then twice
the implementation.
Thirdly
all acts of worship are divided into two
general
into two general categories.
سوره البقره
يقول تعالى الذين يؤمنون بالغيب هذا ايش
هو؟ هذا العلم صح ولا لا؟ الايمان علم ولا
لا؟ الايمان علم مصدق بيقين هذا هو
الايمان
الذين يؤمنون بالغيب
ويقيمون الصلاه ومما رزقناهم ينفقون هي قم
قم
قران الله
اقرا قم قم
‏Number one, he say those who believe in
the unseen. What is belief? Belief is it
starts as knowledge, right? Belief is
knowing the truth and knowing it with
such certainty that it becomes belief.
الله
اقرا قم قم
يؤمنون بالغيب هذا بمنزلت اقرا
ويقيمون الصلاه يا ايها المزمل قم
المزمل
ومما رزقناهم ينفقون قم فانر
[Silence]
‏are into
categories
that which is between the slave and
Allah
it's not between anyone else it's just
between Allah and the slave
and the second is that which is between
the
الله
المتاخرين
العبادات والمعاملات
صلاه
‏and others of
other people for
however
another
‏tyeslaveصران
[Silence]
الذين يؤمنون بالغيب ويقيمون صلاه ومما
رزقناهم ينفقون
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ومما رزقناهم ينفقون
هذه تسمى عند العلماء بالعبادات الخاصه
والعبا العبادات المتعديه
كيف يقولون العلماء
العبادات الخاصه مثل الصلاه مثل الصوم هذه
خاصه بينك وبين الله والعبادات
المتعديه
لانها تتعدى الى الغير مثل الزكاه مثل اي
طاعه الوالدين مثل الى اخره هذه
عبادات متعديه
فالعبادات تنقسم الى قسمين
عبادات خاصه وعبادات ايش
يا اخوه متعديه التي تتعدى الى الاخرين
هذه لغه العلم لابد ما يكفي انه بس ناخذ
معلومات لازم نتعلم لغه
لغه العلماء عشان نفهم على علمائنا
فاذا قرات في الكتاب
وهذه متعديه معناها عباده متعديه تتعدى
الى الغير اذا قرات هذه من ال الخواص او
العبادات الخاصه معناها انها بين الله
وبين العبد
[Silence]
‏urs
people
haveثر
in
that takes place
‏other people
by
this is why two chapter
and now you why those two words even
though theyally mean the same thing they
were very specifically and intentionally
chosen if we were
ان سوره المدثر يا ايها المزمل قم فانذر
او اجينا نركبها على المزمل يا ايها
المدثر قم الليله الا قليلا تزبط بعد ما
نعلم الان الفرق بين المزمل والمدثر
والعباده الخاصه والعباده المتعديه هل
تمشي هذه الان؟ ما تمشي ما تركب اصلا الان
ما تركب وهذا هو بلاغه القران وجمال بلاغه
القران الذي يذكره العلماء لكن يحتاج الى
زي ما بقولوا السوريين يحتاج هز كتاف يعني
الانسان ما بس يحط رجل على رجل ويستلقي
على ظهره ويا عالم علموني لا بده الواحد
بده الواحد يفكر بده يستجمع فكره بده يكون
عنده اسئله بده يكون
يسمع الكلام يحاول يحفظable
[Silence]
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
ان يعلمنا ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا
نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجعل القران
العظيم ربيع قلوبنا ونور صدورنا وجلاء
احزاننا وذهاب همومنا اللهم علمنا منه ما
جهلنا وذكرنا منه ما نسينا اللهم اسلل
اسلل سخيمه قلوبنا واغسل حباتنا
واسقل قلوبنا من الذنوب والمعاصي والران
يا رب العالمين والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا
[Silence]
وعليكم السلامجميع
حي